la deuxième info une étude scientifique
rallye réclamer la reprise britannique
dit qu' il existe sept types de pénis
voilà il ya les crises ou qui le crillon
et wallis et la f1 ouais donc ses
épaules ce qui aide à croquer il ya des
poivrons plus court que la moyenne mais
plus épais sur la longueur
alors c'est plus que de le faire je vais
faire l'appel comme si on était en
classe quand vous entendez quelque chose
qui correspond à notre nom vous le
verrez d'accord crayon créant quatre
heures car on ne tranche de poivrons
plus court que la moyenne mais plus et
pierrot c'est vraiment le pire mais non
banane courbet le flou bananes d'ananas
je les ai vus banane toi ben vous pouvez
lire ce qu'on préférait
[Rires]
non mais sans rigoler des lecteurs avec
toi je veux faire des détecteurs azizi
tu crois que d'ici à 5 ans la wii d'ici
là sous sol causés nazaire à être en
dessous mais elle sans rigoler elles
n'ont lukoil
non mais ça aqualad intéresse oui alors
vous serez alors préférer les bananes
voilà rêver rire la wii très bien donc
d'incomber comme le free cône de glace
et perd la base plus faire la pointe à
ces jeux qu'on n'a pas lui aussi le zizi
trouble et ron mais pour les amateurs de
friandises ya également le champignon
marteau celle inverse du cône de glace
c'était l'idée à oui mais là c'est en
fait à huy à willy comme il est en fait
un nom de bord noir n'y a pas ici n'en
versera saucisse pas grand pas petit
uniformes gilets concourir à grands pas
petit uniforme mais paient les grands
les ponts et gros en fait y en a 4 sur 5
ya pas dix et neuf
mais 90% sont des concombres et bien sûr
avec des particularités
bah alors vous vous excusez moi vous
avez fait une étude non mais j'ai une
petite fierté je policiers l'insee
céline cdi si elle n'est pas allée à
l'est pas du tout vulgaire mais je
pouvais me dit particulier devient j'ai
une fierté gelés par 50 de ma vie 16e
beaucoup extrêmement active in c'est
très très rare que ce soit très très
droit et qu'en salle est beau comme une
tour eiffel quelque chose de très joli
et que je n'ai les grands et quand on a
tous été très clair la nuit en tout cas
l ue vous dire à mon avis à la plus de
visites que la tour eiffel le plus petit
punition quoi alors je crois pas que ce
soit alors le plus petit enis du monde
et vos témoignages
moins d'un centimètre détenteur a pas
voulu en dire plus il a voulu garder
mercenaires avaient souhaité garder
l'anonymat vous avez d'arrêt